مباراته اليوم ضد مدرسة الجيمنازيوم الثانوية
هرتسليا في تل أبيب إليكم الصور وما يليها
وثيقة من الأمس حيث شوهد المخرج زئيف دجاني
ينسق مع الطالب الذي يريد وضع تيفيلين رقم
داخل المدرسة ولكن عند مدخل المدرسة هنا
دعونا نرى لك
أنت من يقوم بعمل هنا
إلى الله جبل ماذا تفعل لماذا معه
علامة لي لوضع علامة
أكمل قبلي
سؤال: الجمعة وأكتوبر قادمان، ماذا هناك لنقوله
إنه لأمر صادم أنهم نسوا معنى أن تكون يهوديًا
القصة مثل إجراء تيفيلين، ما هو الهدف
هذا أمير، ليس له علاقة، الناس لم ينسوا ما هو
كونك يهوديًا، فقد نسي ما يعنيه أن تكون ابنًا
آدم للأسف لها تراها شهر
هذا الأخير في عدة أمور في عدة جوانب
هناك نوع من التكرار، هناك نوع من النسيان، كما تقول
يا لها من ذاكرة قصيرة لدى الجمهور هنا
بهذه السرعة هذه التغييرات وهذا ليس هو الحدث
الأول لديه فجوة كبيرة ولكن بين الجميع
العائلات التي تزن كل شيء للعائلات التي يتم اختطافها
دوائر الاحتياط المصاب نيكيم المحظور
لأن أرواحهم، أقول، أولئك الذين يعودون إلى هذا الخطاب لا يفعلون ذلك
إنه يهتم بما حدث هنا في 7 أكتوبر، كم
ساهمت تصريحات أعضاء الحكومة اليوم
ساعد اليوم أولئك الذين يريدون تدمير إسرائيل هناك
كان الأمر سخيفًا في مسرح مناقشة لا صلة له بالموضوع
ويحدث أن يتم تضمينه في لائحة الاتهام، وهذا سيحدث على أي حال
دعونا لا ندع نيتا آل هامز يديرون داروم
أفريقيا إن لم تكن جنوب أفريقيا الجزائر أو
في بلد آخر كنا سنصل إلى Aeg على أي حال بدون ذلك
علاقة بما كنا نفعله في غزة وما قاله أصدقائي
بالمناسبة، كانت مثل هذه الكنيست وغيرها هي التعبير "لا".
وقال استعداد أعضاء المعارضة أيضا أن هناك
هنا كتب تشويهًا معاديًا للسامية لجنوب إفريقيا
وهو ما تستخدمه حماس فعلاً في الإرهاب الدبلوماسي ضدها
لقد نجحت دولة إسرائيل، للأسف، في تحقيق هذا الهدف بالذات
أننا نتحدث عنه الآن، عن إبادة شعب
ودولة إسرائيل وتزال هذه المناقشة بالذات من وجهة نظرهم
إنه فوز بغض النظر عن النتيجة التي ستكون على أرضنا
الجملة، كما تعلم، سمعناها اليوم في عجوز شمطاء مرة أخرى، أنت بحاجة إلى ذلك
للقول باللغة الإنجليزية وليس باللغة العبرية Sde Pacto
لقد انتقلنا بالفعل إلى المرحلة التالية في هذه الحرب، وهي المرحلة الثالثة هناك
في غزة، وينبغي القول أن هذا يحدث دون أن نحققه
الأهداف الرئيسية التي أعلنتها هي الأسرة
حكم حماس، عودة جميع المختطفين، أمران
هذا لم يحدث ونحن بالفعل في منتصف الحرب
هذا أمر مزعج للغاية، وأنا أتفق معك
لقد كنت في كعكة غزة في الراعي هذا الأسبوع، ولم تعد كذلك
تسمع صوت المدفعية ولا ترى حائل
الهواء ثم مثل النوم يسمى يتلاشى في
يبدأون بالخروج بهدوء هكذا، وهو ما يمثل مشكلة كبيرة لأن
أهداف العملية ما زلنا بعيدين عن الأهداف
بداية عودة المختطفين ووفاة القدرة
حماس كمنظمة عسكرية ومنظمة حكومية وبالتالي
أعتقد أننا يجب أن نتوقف ونفكر الآن
العودة إلى البداية إلى شدة البداية إلى الزخم
الشخص الذي كان لدينا في البداية مريض لأنه إذا لم يكن الأمر كذلك فسوف نصل
إلى حيث قد نرى السنوار
أخرج وأقول مازلت هنا، كل شيء يعود
إلى الروتين وهذا خطير على دولة إسرائيل وليس أنا
أقول لك، أنا عضو في الليكود، وأعمل في الليكود ولكن
من وجهة نظر وطنية، مع رئيس الوزراء وفهم لا
جلب الإنجازات في أهداف الحرب التي حددوها
الأهداف ثم ماذا سيحدث ثم سنكون
داني دانون في ورطة خطيرة في هذه المرحلة لذا غادر
كان داني دانون هو القائد
وإلا فإن نيغا آخر يجب أن يجلب الإنجازات إلى الله
القيادة الأخرى لن تكون قادرة على البقاء في الواقع
الشرق الأوسط أن حماس تهزم دولة إسرائيل
بعد فترة الأسر يقول ما يجب الذهاب إلى الانتخابات
أنا لا أدخل الآن، أنا أثق بمجلس الوزراء
أنه سيتعين على قيادة أخرى القيام بذلك إذا قمت بملء هذا المنصب
المنصب هو أم مجلس الوزراء الذي يتضمن أيضا
ولن تتمكن الأحزاب الأخرى من قيادة الإنجازات
دولة إسرائيل في ورطة بسبب جهاز الأمن
الجنرال يحذر رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو من ذلك
خطر فوري لانتشار الإرهاب في يهودا والسامرة
هذه الأمور نشرها مراسلنا سيفي عوفاديا
حدثنا السياسي شالوم سيفي
نعم يعني أن هذا هو مصدر القلق الحقيقي الذي نتحدث عنه
تحذير استراتيجي يتم تسليمه شخصيًا إلى الرأس
ووضعت حكومة بنيامين نتنياهو على مكتبه
ويتحدث هذا التحذير عن الخوف من اشتعال النيران في الوقت المناسب
الأقرب في يهودا والسامرة نتيجة الضغط
كما أن الاضطرابات الاقتصادية المتزايدة ليست كذلك
عمال الكنيست عشرات الآلاف من العمال الفلسطينيين
إن عدم الدخول للعمل في أراضي إسرائيل أمر مهين للغاية
في الاقتصاد هناك أيضا المال كأموال الضرائب التي تسبب
لخفض رواتب الآليات الأمنية من الناس
ليست آليات الأمن الفلسطيني هي محل الاهتمام هنا
فقط بحاجة إلى فهم يعني ليس فقط لأنه
زيادة في الإرهاب أو من اندلاع موجة
الإرهاب هو الخوف من اختلاق ما أسموه الانقلاب
القصب يعني السلاح الذي تملكه السلطة العليا حاليا
من قبل الأجهزة الأمنية الفلسطينية
ضدنا، ضد مقاتلي الجيش الإسرائيلي، ضد المستوطنين
في يهوذا وشمرون